what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to feminist brainwashing
this was sent to me by one of my
subscribers he says that there's some
things that I got wrong on my channel
which I know shocking sometimes I can't
be wrong so before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way in and let's
get started it's easier to fool people
than to convince them they have been
fooled Mark Twain while I know the
Duluth model has been talked about a lot
before a woman from the UK who read my
book discovered a quote from Ellen Pence
one of duluth's three co-founders and
shared it with me I found it so
disturbing that after looking into it
further I dropped the other three
projects I'm working on to make this
video before the implementation of the
Duluth model domestic violence was
linked to drug abuse or communication
skills and an inability to handle stress
anger or frustration not aggressively
even back then this view was supported
by both real life experience as well as
peer-reviewed science studies can
conducted since the implementation of
the Duluth model continuously confirmed
this view however for purposes of our
discussion we need to Define some terms
the first term is entryism Wikipedia
defines entryism as follows entryism is
a political strategy in which an
organization or state encourages its
members or supporters to join another
usually larger organization in an
attempt to expand and influence their
ideas and program in situations where
the organization being entered is
hostile to entryism the interests May
engage in a degree of subterfuge or
subversion to hide the fact that they
are an organization in their own right
the second term is I don't get it did
you get it sorry guys
I'm gonna just keep watching it oh my
God brainwashing which is defined by
Merriam-Webster's Dictionary as a
forcible indoctrination to induce
someone to give up basic political
social or religious beliefs and
attitudes and to accept contrasting
regimented ideas persuasion by
Propaganda or san salesmanship Yuri
bezemoff a former KGB agent during the
Cold War working for communist Russia
who defected to the West referred to
political brainwashing as ideological
subversion Yuri defines ideological
subversion as follows to change the
perception of reality of every American
to such an extent that despite the
abundance of information no one is able
to come to a sensible conclusions in the
interests of Defending themselves their
families their community and their
country with that on the way let's move
on now the quote came from a book called
coordinating Community responses
domestic violence lessons from Duluth
and Beyond published by Sage publishing
in 1999 and it's co-authored by Melanie
F Shepard and Alan Pence and of course
Ellen Pence was the original person who
helped co-found the Duluth model this
appears to be a college textbook that
isn't available in the vast majority of
local libraries or bookstores that
normally don't carry College texts
further even in the places it sold
purchase new even the ebook itself is
over forty five dollars my guess is that
even though this book is probably used
in women's and gender studies programs
around the world the vast majority of
the public is unaware of its existence
while I didn't read the entire book the
quote provided to me was from chapter 2
entitled some thoughts on philosophy
written by Ellen Pence herself so I
decided to start my investigation by
reading the entirety of chapter 2. in
this next section I'll be quoting large
portions of the chapter because Ellen
Pence's words put the Duluth model and
its motives in brutal perspective in the
chapter Pence goes into detail about who
the Duluth model staff were and what
kind of legal experience they had she
states the daip staff project organizers
spent eight months learning all aspects
of the system from practitioners in each
of the participating agencies the
project organizers consisted of three
women Shirley oberg was one of the
original organizers of the shelter and
well known and respected by all agency
directors her reputation and ability to
talk about being abused without being
dismissed open all the key doors for us
Carol McDonald had been a volunteer at
the shelter she had considerable
experience in office management and made
us look far more professional than we
actually were at the time I was the
third an outsider from Minneapolis whose
father was a Salesman and mother a
Catholic my specialty was selling guilt
okay so these are from the people that
got the Duluth model of abuse I'm sorry
guys I'm sorry this might be a video of
me just being confused so from this
description it's clear that she admits
that these women were not only not legal
Scholars they didn't have any
professional education or training in
any field associated with law or any of
the real oh I get it so they're the ones
that started I forgot what it was called
but they said in the beginning of the
video and that's like the the abuse
model that a lot of people are using
today to like determine what abuse is
and those three girls had no legal
expertise is what they're saying and
science is associated with any of the
issues that they were dealing with they
were just man-hating feminists activists
Pence admits that they put up a false
front by pretending to be professional
and that her specialty was to use guilt
to unethically manipulate people to
supporting her in effect she's admitting
that she and her colleagues were in fact
con artists when discussing how domestic
violence differed from other crimes
Pence States daip staff agreed that it
was about the nature of the relationship
but wanted to shift the focus on
Intervention from fixing or ending the
relationship to confronting what seems
to be a sense of entitlement to use
coercion intimidation or violence in
this relationship that is not
permissible in other social
Relationships by making this shift it
was assumed that the whole center of
attention would shift from resolving the
conflict to challenging the use of
violence in other words they didn't care
about conflict resolution between the
parties or whether or not the alleged
victim left her man they exclusively
focused on the allegations alone Pence
goes on so they're saying I think this
is one it shifted from being about real
abuse to like more about allegations of
it I think I think and it and it's
basically saying the people that kind of
inspired this shift made it so I'm sorry
guys
um I made it like they they didn't have
any legal experience they were
man-hitting feminists and they admitted
that they were selling guilt the daip
staff argued against the use of causal
explanations that require practitioners
to assume a fairly Universal
psychological makeup among batterers in
other words they actively ignored all
the scientifically documented reasons
domestic violence occurs they just
dismissed it continuing on the power and
control wheel which was developed by
battered women attending women's groups
was originally a description of the
typical behaviors accompanying the
violence in effect it said when he is
violent he gets power and he gets
control however we change the message to
he is violent in order to get control or
power we okay we changed the message
that he is violent to get controller
power from when he is violent he gets
control and power the difference is not
semantic it is ideological he does it
for power he does it for control and he
does it because he can these were
advocacy Jingles that in our opinion
said about everything there was to say
by determining that the need or desire
for power was the motivating force
behind battering we created a conceptual
framework that in fact did not fit the
live experience of many of the men and
women we were working with the daip
staff remained undaunted by the
difference in our Theory and the actual
experiences of those we were working
with we all engaged in ideological
practices and claimed them as neutral
observations I don't really understand
what's the difference between when he is
violent he gets power and control and he
is violent in order to get power and
control do you see a difference in those
statements yeah the first one when he is
violent he gets power and he gets
control he's violent just means that for
me looking at it looks like that's who
is when the first one when he is violent
seems like sometimes he might be violent
first one the last one is that he is
violent in order to get control Powers
more like oh
she's doing it to get power and control
of the first is like he's a violent
person and when he's violent yeah that's
what happens yeah okay and they're
saying that basically they were working
with these women and
that wasn't what they saw but they their
ideology surpassed that okay simply put
they unethically misrepresented the
reports from women's groups to fit their
bigoted feminist narratives then they
pretended their dishonesty was an
unbiased observation Pence goes on
eventually we began to give into the
process that is the heart of the Duluth
model it was the cases themselves that
created the [__] in each of our
theoretical suits of armor I found that
many of the men I interviewed did not
seem to articulate the desire for power
over their partner although I
relentlessly took every opportunity to
point out to men in the groups that they
were so motivated and merely in denial
and the fact that few men ever
articulated such a desire went unnoticed
by me and many of my co-workers
eventually we realized that we were
finding what we had already
predetermined to find when we had to
start explaining women's violence toward
their Partners lesbian violence and the
violence of men who did not like what
they were doing we were brought back to
our original undeveloped thinking in
other words not only were the Duluth
staff views ordered by the evidence they
were directly contradicted by it they
accidentally debunked their own feminist
Narrative of patriarchal oppression and
debunked feminist ideology at the same
time she continues the victim blaming
accusations in the system coupled with
Advocates false representation of women
as having no agency everything she did
wrong he made her do plague us to this
day everything she did wrong okay well
oh I see oh my God so that's kind of
what we hear today on the show he made
me crazy it's clear that every Community
can find the case of a woman who lied
all women are suspect for more than a
decade the daip and shelter Advocates
reacted to this constant undercurrent of
women or Liars by arguing that women are
Saints uh oh victim mentality yeah no
that's so it's like when they're saying
it's kind of like it's kind of taboo
when I question a girl on assault or
grape or any of that stuff and it's kind
of like they're saying that all women
are Saints basically and they're saying
that the men wanted the power and
control when really sometimes like women
push guys to be violent because they're
so like they'll they'll say like
horrible horrible thing like we don't
want to have this conversation but there
are times and I'm not saying men should
be violent like in these situations but
but I'm saying there's stop putting your
hands over your head I'm saying I'm
saying this verbal abuse you know and
like that we don't talk about that how
sometimes like girls will say like the
craziest dudes and then he'll snap like
even like Chris Brown and Rihanna you
know she was hitting him first but
everyone painted her out to be the saint
who did no wrong turn to Blind Eye to
some women's use of violence oh see
they're they're okay their drug use and
alcoholism and often their harsh and
violent treatment of their children
there did not seem to be a way to
acknowledge these problems and still
argue that this was a deeply gendered
issue and this is I think this is the
all of
that is built on I
think in the comments but wow that's
the one of the three girls that worked
there this passage is particularly
damning because even back then Pence
admit she knew that domestic violence
Advocates were Liars further she and her
colleagues were well aware of how common
false accusations were and they ignored
it they were so desperate to make this a
gendered issue they actively ignored
evidence that disproved their bigotry
while actively trying to cover up any
evidence that disproved their
conclusions she goes on the daip first
moved to strengthen the protection order
process then pursued a fairly aggressive
Criminal Court intervention process the
Civil protection order process was
faster less adversarial more consistent
and more focused on the pattern of abuse
than an incident most important it
resulted in Practical court ordered
release relevant to the needs of the
victims housing child support and
enhanced police protection so we pursued
a criminalization path to change the
climate of Tolerance and created a
gender deterrence to battering and a
civil process to address the immediate
needs of victims this approach left us
with the question of what to do when the
victims failed to cooperate with our
criminalization agenda our solution was
to pursue cases even when a victim does
not want it we had to neutralize the
offender's ability to control the
process by getting the victim to ask to
have the charges drop thus a no drop
policy is that true so so women can not
like even if they don't want someone to
press charges like the state will still
do it oh my God I think that is I feel
like I've heard that somewhere we had
this idea that a primary objective
should be to shift the burden of
Confrontation of abusers from the victim
onto the system this meant police could
no longer ask the victim whether she
wanted him arrested thus our mandatory
arrest policy okay so now they're saying
like victims don't have to confront
their abusers that the system will do it
for them okay I think I understand what
makes a statement so damning is that
Pence admits that even women opposed to
loose feminist bigotry so they silence
them by creating policies that ignored
the wishes of these women however just
as bad is that Pence admits the Duluth
staff had a hidden agenda of trying to
criminalize family law issues such as
child support divorce rape Etc even more
damage Pence admits that one of the
Duluth model's primary objectives was to
violate men's U.S constitutional right
to confront their accusers she actually
wait wow we admitted this was one of
their primary goals to clarify find lost
States the Sixth Amendment to the U.S oh
my God and they kind of go around that
because we were looking at the last
video right remember okay because they
kind of figured it out because remember
the girl can accuse the guy of abuse I
say all that stuff in civil court and
still remember in the last video so she
can go to civil court say he abused me
say he did all the stuff to me and still
and then he could lose his kids his car
has everything yep so in a way they kind
of did it I doubt they did that in
criminal court but I think they did it
inside I mean we're going to learn but I
I it doesn't seem okay is the sound off
it's made in court and statements made
outside of court that are offered as
evidence during the trial now returning
back to chapter two and Pence's words
she goes on to admit the Duluth model
has been hailed as an organizer's
miracle I always think that the daip was
not an organizing Miracle as much as
that the city of Duluth was an
organizer's Miracle town we have the
luxury of working in a community where
as these issues and contradictions are
raised key practitioners in the system
take them up as legitimate institutional
concerns in other words these feminist
bigots wouldn't have been so successful
had it not been for the involvement of
white Knights and cucks while Pence's
words are a damn mission of dishonesty
bigotry and a hatred of men it's clear
that these feminists also had a hidden
agenda to use a Duluth model to idea
logically subvert and brainwash Society
into changing the way people perceive
men and they male female relationship
today oh my God so they just wanted
women to be victim and that was their
goal and they were saying they ignored
all the evidence that was in front of
them because they wanted to be a
gendered issue men are being arrested
for spreading their legs on public
transit a man was jailed for over two
months for looking into a shop window
during business hours successful men are
being falsely accused of sexual assault
and DV daily further in some places men
are jailed for merely complimenting a
woman's looks a woman's mere accusation
unsupported by any evidence will now
destroy a man's career and his social
standing in society even more
frightening the Duluth model is the most
widely used domestic violence
Intervention Program in the world wow
the most widely used intervention Pro
wow and it was from three feminists one
who agreed or openly admitted that they
were trying to make it a gendered issue
and they wanted women to be victim even
in places where it's not used programs
are modeled after it judges doctors
lawyers military personnel police EMTs
teachers and everyone else is being
institutionally brainwashed with Duluth
model training to perceive men as
abusers and women as victims this has
led to innocent men being systemically
discriminated against while women guilty
of abuse and other crimes not only don't
often get charged for their crimes but
even when convicted the courts give them
a slap on the wrist feminists have
ideologically subverted Society based on
a lie created by the Duluth model and
the Duluth model co-founder Ellen Pence
admits it wow knowing this the question
that begs to be asked is how many
millions of men have been wrongfully
targeted and suffered as a direct result
of this systemic feminist bigotry you
know I wish I had a legal solution for
this however because feminists
completely saturate and control courts
Academia and the media even challenging
the Duluth scheme to violate men's Sixth
Amendment constitutional right to
confront their accusers will most likely
be an uphill battle wait I wonder in
normal Court can do men still get to
confront their accusers or no yes no no
I don't know either anyone who attempted
to legally challenge it in fact it's my
view this kind of makes me look at all
these like me too like a lot of cases
that came forward even like Harvey
Weinstein right like clearly he
shouldn't be selling for roles right
that that's that's not correct
um however all the girls that came
forward like you weren't assaulted by
him you wanted the role and you had sex
with him to get it I don't really think
they're victim you know what I mean like
the real victim to the women's that were
overlooked for the role because they
wouldn't sleep with him not the women
that slept with him got famous off it
you know what I mean no I mean like how
are you like I'm sorry if I if I had to
get a job and I had to sleep with
someone to get a job I wouldn't do it
and there's no way in hell that you
could offer me anything to do that so if
you did it you're not a victim you're
that's who you are and I mean I don't
you know Aguila forced prostitution oh I
don't know because it might depend on
someone's situation I don't think it's
like I think okay if someone is doing
that you know what I'm like I don't know
go to like his boss or go to the
authorities and if it doesn't work go
work for someone else like if if I had a
guy that wanted to sleep with me to get
a role like I just wouldn't sleep with
him and again the real victims are the
women that didn't do it but you're
you're going to tell me you got these
roles you got famous off these rolls you
made a lot of money off these roles you
were quiet until all the other girls
came out and now you're a victim like
it's just it's just it's we I I think
the real victims are the women that
didn't do it but now we have to think
like remember everything we're looking
at is brainwashed by this like this
model that everything's based off of
because they literally want to see women
as victims and this makes so much sense
on my show when I say like women want to
be victim because we're like as a
society program to see women as victims
oh my God just made a lot of anyone who
attempts to challenge the Duluth scheme
to violate a man's new process rights
should be prepared to take it to the
United States Supreme Court given that
it's currently more conservative than
liberal it's the only place anyone is
likely to see Justice even then it won't
be easy until then men need to disappear
avoid commitment avoid cohabitation
avoid marriage and if you're dating do
everything in your power to mitigate the
potential for a false accusation of
domestic violence or rape okay so this
makes a lot of sense so men are walking
away to change the laws that's why
they're walking away so a lot of times
they like paint them as these in cells
but it's just like the whole system is
against men even the court system are
it's kind of run by feminism yeah I'm
looking into this next student what are
you looking up no I was actually looking
at the Duluth model because um probably
well it's funded to reduce domestic
violence against women I don't know I
don't know where he goes into that
because this is my first time hearing
this so I'm still trying to like get
hold of it is it a system that was
developed to increase
um what would I say is it developed to
reduce domestic violence against women
or was there a system developed for men
to easily be targeted for domestic abuse
um it seems like both it's like okay we
listened okay because remember this is
what it said it said there's three women
that started it and none of them really
had a legal background and they kind of
made it seem like they were more legit
than they were and she openly admitted
that she wanted to make it a gendered
issue and even didn't let them if the
victim didn't want to press charges she
said the state could take it into their
hands and press charges for the victim
yeah because
um there's a critics critics argue that
the method can be ineffective as it was
developed without minority communities
in mind and can fail to address root
psychological or emotional causes of
abuse in addition to completely
neglecting male victims female
perpetrators of abuse so it's one-sided
in a way yeah well this this was really
I was really confused in the beginning I
kind of get it I feel like I still I
need a little more so let me know in the
comments what videos I should react to
next subscribe to the channel I think
blessing is gonna like never live with a
girl ever by the end of these he's like
take your stuff home
[Laughter]
okay guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time